[Music]
he
okay
let's
so here this arm I want here here okay
I'm not doing my Shir like this right
then as he goes to push I can take this
over here he keeps pushing I go
inside wrap down push get out of the way
pushing then you can add your
movement so I'm going to move
out
okay get out from under here your
spiraling geometry okay so when I when I
go I don't want to Pummel in here on
this straight line so I'm already
rotating the fight and he's going to
press again and I'm rotating fight again
you
see it I know it looks doable you're all
on this straight line and you go
here but you want this thing to rotate
boom goes around boom
so I'm going to turn it one way he comes
the other way comes in again and I'm
inside never here in place I know it
looks doable but your performance
onvelope
go
pushing okay keep it rotating all right
let's
go
[Music]
sh
and move out from under
him no I
p on his push he comes in this time I'm
going to fade I'm going to fade back
with the same
foot a lot of times when he's driving
really hard you can't turn into that
thing but this is where O's Yin yield
comes in okay so I'm here
R just circle that last little
bit
okay let's try it uh he does he might be
on your hip but he doesn't have to be on
your hip okay so I'm moving this way and
he now charges so fast there's no way I
going to do it inside turn on
that so one I come out
here
the key is that you're not here shoving
you need him to go more deeper and
that's where ense yield happens so he's
pushing
and just like tension knock I'm here hit
but now I
yeld
okay let's
[Music]
go
got to let more Yin the yin is way more
important than the
[Music]
Y this time I keep the the head hook I
don't try to
P one here
so don't lose the
head you're still going to pull this arm
you're still going to pull the arm okay
but it's with your
weight and he's still got some pressure
there's some pressure here okay pressure
I'm going to go
under okay let's so let me help you with
the geometry okay look he's going to do
a forward roll do you see you're going
to do the front inward position you
understand say yes yes so your body has
to be inside of that okay so he's going
to do the front inward
Kazi well I can't be here you see and I
can't be here so I'm going to
disappear
now if you look at that this foot goes
in I turn and I'm going to be
here okay and I go all the way
down because I'm throwing the I'm not
throwing just a throw so in and I I sink
inside of that forward
roll see how you're fitting
unite your body don't leave your head up
there my body is connected to this hand
Bo this hand drops it's going to drop
with
me
okay F your
geometry
[Music]
too much ad me you need more
Yin
start
again
that's
it do it like that again that was
it keep bring that head with
you there you go